it is my pleasure today to welcome to
the program
professor olivier siboni at hec
paris as well as co-author of the book
noise a flaw in human judgment
co-written by daniel kahneman as well as
cass sunstein cassie
a multi-time guest on the program before
uh olivier it's so great to have you on
today
thanks for having me so maybe to start
with to kind of introduce some of the
things we're talking about
many of us can imagine situations in
which
the inputs seem to be the same
it might be a situation where a patient
goes to two different doctors with the
same
symptoms or a driver is driving
and there is a situation with some
pedestrians and vehicles where
the circumstances seem to be the same
but there's
something we call human judgment that is
applied which sometimes gets
each individual to make a different
decision
whether it's driving whether it's about
a diagnostic test that a doctor wants to
do
in in your world how do you start
quantifying
this x factor of human judgment and
thinking about
it in a way that we can start making
some observations about it
let's first start by double clicking on
what you call
human judgment here because in the
examples you've taken yes we have human
judgment
in some cases we also have human
judgment but we don't
mind variation so say
we are deciding you know what what hotel
we prefer in a foreign city or or what
dish we prefer in the menu
it's fine if you and i disagree right
that's not something where we
where we expect uniformity the the
problem that we've been
writing about in noise is when we have
human judgment on which we expect
uniformity on which we think there is a
correct answer
for instance as you said when a patient
is visiting a doctor
the diagnosis should not be a matter of
opinion it should not be a matter of
taste or preference it should be
a matter of professional judgment and we
pretty much expect that different
doctors would come to the same judgment
and the problem is quite often they
don't
and that's what we call noise the
unwanted variability in human judgment
what are the factors that we what are
the categories of factors that can
create these
differences you know i remember reading
about in fact it may have been a daniel
kahneman book now i don't remember
offhand
about sentencing in criminal cases
and how one factor that affected
sentencing was
is it close to lunchtime or is it after
lunch time in other words how hungry is
the judge
seemed to play a role in determining a
sentence what
what category would that type of of
a judgment discrepancy
fall under and what types of categories
are there
so this category though the example you
take here which is a famous study of
judicial decisions is what we call
occasion
noise occasion noise is the fact that
the same people
looking at the same facts on two
different occasions
will sometimes not have exactly the same
judgment so
a judge looking at the same defendant
try it for the same case
before lunch or after lunch will not
have exactly the same judgment and by
the way
this is true also of factors such as the
temperature
whether the weather is sunny or rainy
whether the judge's favorite football
team won
or lost the game the previous day and
whether the previous cases that the
judge looked at
were favorable or unfavorable so there
are a lot of factors that are going to
influence a judge that are completely
extraneous to the case that should have
nothing to do with the case but
influence it
that's what we call occasion noise it's
variation
within the person and we can all feel
this
when we when we know oh i made that
decision because i was in a bad mood if
i think back on it
i would have made a different decision
now that i'm in a good mood right that's
that's fairly intuitive we're aware of
that we probably underestimate it but
we're
aware of it that's one of the categories
can you give us some of the other other
categories
sure so another category which is
relatively easy to wrap your mind around
is if you take again the example of
judges that people have different
average levels of severity so some
judges are going to be tough
hanging judges other judges are going to
be more lenient they are you know the
bleeding hard judges who feel for the
defendant
if you give these two judges the same 20
different cases
of course each of the 20 cases is
different but the average sentence
that the bleeding heart judge gives is
going to be a lot less than the average
sentence and the heart judge gives
that's what we call level noise and then
there is a third category
which is a bit harder to wrap your mind
around but which is
actually the most important one and it's
easy to
to see if you think again of the judges
take these two judges the linear one
and the and the tough one not only do
they disagree
on the average level of their sentences
they're also going to disagree on each
case
if you ask them to rank the cases from
the the worst case to the least severely
punishable case
they are not going to agree on the
ranking because basically they have
different tastes
they are different individuals they have
different life experiences
they have different preferences they may
have different political
opinions basically they see different
things in the cases that they look at
they have different patterns of judgment
and that's what we call pattern noise so
we have
occasion noise we have level nose we
have pattern noise
when you put all those things together
you have a lot of reasons
for judgments that should be identical
ideally
to in fact differ and differ quite a bit
so there are people who are maybe
technocratic by nature who when you
present this to them
they would come up with a solution maybe
when it comes to the sentencing question
or maybe when it comes to
um when a patient comes in with certain
complaints what's the path of testing
that that should be done
where they would essentially say we need
to eliminate
some of this variability we will use a
computer program of some kind
artificial intelligence we put in the
inputs and it tells us
this person should get seven years in
prison
and everybody gets seven years in prison
or this patient should get the cat scan
this one should not that would be one
approach to this
is that does that account for
the true nature of complexity
with many of these situations or would
would that solution leave
something out that's important well
there is a difficult tradeoff to make
here
what is guaranteed is that if you do
what you just described you will
eliminate the noise
yes because whatever system whatever
rule whatever algorithm whatever
formula you put in place is going to be
noise-free and that's why
it's often when you actually measure the
performance of
algorithms and rules and so on it's
often quite good
because it eliminates the noise the
level noise the occasion noise the
pattern knows it basically makes sure
that when you have the same inputs you
will have the same output
now does that make does that necessarily
make rules and algorithms a good thing
no because noise is not the only way you
can be wrong you can also have bias
so suppose to take an extreme but not
completely crazy case
that you have a rule that says anyone
who's been sentenced
of this particular crime gets exactly
this punishment
or anyone who's been sentenced three
times of a felony
goes to jail for life three three
strikes and you're out yes well you've
eliminated
noise there at least if you apply the
rule but a lot of people would say
you've created another form of error
which is a form of bias
which is that you are giving too severe
a sentence to a lot of people who would
not
deserve that sentence yes you've
eliminated the unwanted variability
between people who have committed the
same three crimes but you've added a lot
of bias in the form of unwanted severity
against people who have committed three
not so bad crimes
so there's a trade-off between how
accurate and how
unbiased an algorithm or rule can be
and the fact that it will be noise-free
because that trade-off is a difficult
one there is going to be lots of cases
where
in fact you will have to continue to
resort to human judgment you cannot
replace it with a rule
and therefore you need to try to make it
better less noisy without eliminating
the human component
where where biases affect human judgment
sometimes it has been argued that
being aware of these biases can help
mitigate their
impact so whether it's availability bias
or whether it's confirmation bias that
understanding that this is something
that might impact
our judgment helps us to reduce it when
it comes to
noise is is awareness also useful
in mitigating it in an individual or is
it less useful
so first of all for bias there isn't
actually a lot of evidence that simply
being aware of biases
is an effective lasting sustainable way
to reduce your biases
it doesn't work that well awareness is
good right it makes you more
careful but it's not in itself
sufficient
for noise it's even worse okay because
here's the problem of noise
you don't know which way it's going to
make you go wrong you don't know of
all the possible sources of noise of
everything that affects you in a
particular occasion
or for your individual preferences that
could be different from somebody else's
of all the factors that can influence
you on a particular case
you don't know in what direction it's
going to make you go wrong so you need
to actually take
a stance that we call decision hygiene
that is a form of prevention against
noise without knowing how noise is going
to affect you
the reason we call it decision hygiene
uh which is slightly off-putting and
that's intentional
is that we we liken this to
washing your hands when you wash your
hands
you don't know what germs you're
eliminating you you're not saying oh
this is the covid virus and this is the
flu virus and have you ever needed these
two particular things
right and in fact if you're successful
you will never know what problem you've
prevented
but you know that it's good discipline
that it's good practice that it's good
hygiene likewise everything that you do
in your decision making process
ahead of the decision ahead of time to
make your decision process
more disciplined is going to improve the
quality of your decisions because it's
going to make you less noisy when it
comes to institutions versus individuals
noise at the institutional level
sometimes can lead to what what some
call
systemic types of biases you could
imagine how
noise and human judgment might lead to
racial discrimination in housing
decisions for example or
transportation decisions about where
should the stops for the subway line be
which could be influenced by
all all of these types of factors do you
approach
institutional decision making noise
differently than for example
a doctor or a driver making a decision
about an individual patient for example
we actually view the doctor as part of
an institution okay when you only see
one doctor you will never know if your
doctor is noisy you go to your doctor
your doctor tells you you have the flu
you go home you
take your medicine and it gets better or
it doesn't get better you will never
know
whether another doctor in the same
hospital would have told you no it's not
the flu it's because it 19 right
or it's not the flu it's something else
so if you
think about who should take care of
noise it's actually always the
institution
as individuals we can try to make
ourselves more disciplined
but the institution whether it's the
hospital the justice system
the uh you know the the organization
that takes care of hiring individuals or
the the company that has a hiring
process all those institutions should
try to reduce
both the noise and the biases in their
decisions and if they put in place good
decision hygiene practices they will
reduce noise they will also at the same
time reduce the sorts of systemic biases
that you're talking about because when
you put in place good decision practices
you will make your decisions less
exposed less dependent
less sensitive to the biases of
individuals
the last thing i wanted to talk about is
whether there are some cases where
where maybe both noise and bias
are good in the sense that they are sort
of what makes us uniquely
human and the example that i will give
is as we learn more about
autonomous vehicles and the decisions
that
drivers are sometimes making almost
intuitively in a fraction of a second
about for example
merging in a rotary or traffic circle
whether it's the right time or it's not
the right time
or about getting through a yellow light
or not this is something that
it's really been reduced to its it's
happening in a very very small amount of
time
and we're sort of intuitively
considering the position of pedestrians
and how far we are from the light
in some of these cases there will be
variability
but it seems that that it's actually
quite hard
to replicate it accurately with an
artificial intelligence or or with
computers what about those cases where
noise seems to be a sort of uniquely
human ability to make these judgment
calls in a very small amount of time
so we wouldn't call this noise we would
say that those
quick decisions that you're talking
about are system one decisions there are
decisions that are made
without consciously thinking about what
you're doing and that are based on a lot
of learning that has taken place
they can be excellent decisions that you
can have great
instincts if you have been well trained
you can have acquired
expertise at something so if you are a
formula one driver
your your instincts to drive a formula
one car
are extraordinarily fine extraordinarily
fine-tuned and you're able to make
you know decisions in a fraction of a
second that
quite likely would be difficult for a
computer to make
now is this a case of noise we wouldn't
call this a case of noise in the sense
that those decisions are
hypothetically as you as you describe
them good they're actually
consistent the the the expert would make
the same decision a lot of times when
faced with the same situation
where we would see noise is when
a person making a decision is not
consistent and different people are not
consistent with each other in the
decisions that they make
and that creates variability that is not
the case in the example you were talking
about where
presumably there there may be humans who
are better than machines and that will
remain the case for
a long time in a lot of important
decisions so those it's it's really a
different category altogether
yes um and and there will be you know we
i i don't want to give the impression
that that machines are the solution to
everything and and clearly they aren't
and that's why we're writing this book
that actually talks not about how to
eliminate human judgment but how to
replace it
there will be lots of decisions that we
will want humans to make either because
it's too difficult to
have a machine that makes it or because
we don't want
the machine to make it in our place
because we we care about dealing with
a different human being we want to give
people a sense of agency we want to give
people who interact with the decision
the dignity of dealing with the human
being and not with the machine
there are lots of very valid reasons to
retain human judgment
and when that is the case we need to
make sure that those judgments
if they cannot be the sort of expert
snap second judgments that you are
talking about
that they are made in a considered
careful way so that they are less noisy
more just
and less prone to error that uh that
that makes a lot of sense
uh we've been speaking about the book
noise of flying human judgment
co-written by daniel kahneman cass
sunstein
and our guest today professor olivier
ciboni
uh so great having you on i really
appreciate your time today
thank you very much david